okay welcome back everybody so this is
going to be a fun lecture we're going to
take Fourier series which we've defined
as kind of a coordinate transformation
of functions and we're going to derive
the Fourier transform which is a
continuous function that exists for
almost all normal functions that we you
think about and then on Monday we're
gonna start looking at properties of the
Fourier transform that might allow us to
solve partial differential equations
more easily okay I'm gonna be out of
town next Wednesday and Friday and then
the following Monday is also a school
holiday so you won't see me for three
lectures and so I've posted three old
lectures that I've already recorded on
how to do discrete Fourier transforms or
fast Fourier transforms in a computer so
these are some of my favorite lectures
they talk about image compression audio
compression fast Fourier transforms in a
computer and they start to pave the way
for actually numerically simulating
pretty complicated PDEs in a computer
okay so we'll talk more about that kind
of on Monday and then when I get back
the following like four lectures later
so I just want to show you this video
that I made this is for a paper that I
just submitted well sorry I submitted it
a year ago and they just got back to me
which happens unfortunately sometimes
and what we have here is this cool color
plot here is essentially some kind of a
partial differential equation in the
spatial domain okay this is think of
this as space I like to think of these
as like simulated make-believe weather
patterns and I've made it so that the
left side always equals the right side
and the bottom always equals the top and
so if you imagine taking this rectangle
and gluing together the top and the
bottom you get a tube right if I glue
together the top and the bottom I get a
tube and then if I glue this side to
this side I turn it around I get a
doughnut okay
if I have periodic boundary conditions
top and bottom left and right then I'm
at my spatial domain onto a doughnut so
this is super esoteric these are
make-believe weather patterns on a
doughnut planet okay
but the way that I generate these is
kind of interesting so in the frequency
domain in the Fourier transform domain I
have these same coordinates and every IJ
location in this Fourier transform
domain corresponds to a sine wave in x
times the sine wave in Y at that given
frequency so these are higher frequency
sine waves in X&Y these are lower
frequency sine waves in X&Y and I take
these five different frequencies spatial
frequencies these different IJ locations
and I essentially drive them with some
kind of an Eau de I have them
oscillating and I have them decaying at
some slow rates and I'm plotting the
inverse Fourier transform in the real
domain so some of what we're going to be
doing in the continuous Fourier integral
in the three video recorded lectures for
next week we're going to start to see
how we would actually code these up in a
computer with the screen Fourier
transforms and you can do some pretty
pretty neat things for example one thing
you can do imagine that I'm trying to
predict the weather on this doughnut
okay but sampling stations are expensive
if I want to actually measure the
weather conditions at a location on this
doughnut earth it might be really
expensive it might cost me tens of
thousands of dollars to build a weather
station in Antarctica or in Africa or
anywhere and so maybe I only get to
measure at 15 or 20 locations on the
surface of this planet right maybe I
only get to measure at 15 or 20
locations in the ocean or in the Gulf of
Mexico can I back out what the weather
looks like at every other point by
inferring what these Fourier
coefficients are okay that's one type of
problem that we can do now I'll tell you
a lot more about this I just wanted to
show you the cool picture and
you kind of primed for thinking about
you know in this lecture we're gonna be
talking about continuous Fourier
transforms but I want you to be thinking
about Fourier transforms on discrete
arrays of numbers maybe 128 by 128 and
what that would look like okay so let's
get started okay so there's a few things
to do today okay so in the last lecture
I told you that sines and cosines are
not quite enough by themselves right I
can use sines to approximate odd
functions cosines to approximate even
functions but if I want to approximate
any function I need more than just sines
and cosines and so I introduced these
functions e to the I n X okay so these
have a cosine and an imaginary sorry a
cosine and an imaginary sine part and if
I you know and I might have some
coefficient out here this could be a
complex coefficient okay so these are
going to serve as a basis these serve as
a basis for periodic functions on the
interval 0 to 2pi ok so any periodic
function that you can name that doesn't
blow up catastrophic ly to infinity we
can write as an infinite sum of these
basis functions
we also have e to the I each of the 2 I
2 pi an x over L this is a basis for 0
to L right if I have a function defined
on some other interval that's not 0 to 2
pi I just rescale all of my frequencies
by 2 PI over L ok I'm just changing
space and breathe dilating space to be
in this interval instead of this
interval okay and remember this l2 of 0
L is just fancy notation for any nice
well-behaved function that doesn't
integrate to infinity over this domain
whose square doesn't integrate to
infinity over this domain ok so I said
that these serve as a basis for an
infinite dimensional function space
there's infinitely many of these basis
functions right one for every possible
NN equals 1 2 3 up to infinity so one
thing i want to show you is that let's
call these fee of n so the nth function
is this so I want to show you that these
fee of n serve as an ortho orthogonal
basis they're not just a basis but
they're actually orthogonal to each
other okay Sophie n is an orthogonal
basis orthogonal sure oh so what does it
mean for a basis to be orthogonal
what does it mean for X Y & Z to be an
orthogonal basis
what does it mean to be perpendicular
zero inner product orthogonal just means
perpendicular it's a fancy word for
perpendicular and having zero inner
product is how we quantify whether
things are perpendicular okay so this
basis is orthogonal all of these
functions or R are orthogonal to each
other if their inner products are zero
okay so let's just recall what our inner
product is so what is the inner product
of V and the emp'd mode the M function
with V n what is this function inner
product that we defined last time
how do I measure how close to functions
are the integral of the product and one
of them has to be conjugated okay so
it's the integral I'm gonna do it from
minus PI to PI but you could do it from
0 to 2 pi or 1 to 2 pi plus 1 it doesn't
matter of BM x fie n conjugates DX right
that's our inner product this will tell
me how close these two vectors are and
so I'm just going to plug these in
that's integral minus PI to PI of e to
the I MX what's the complex conjugate of
e to the minus I NX
what's either the I and X that's just
coasts an X plus I sine and s so the
conjugate e to the I M X conjugate is
coasts minus I sine and the only like
another way I could get that is by
saying that's e to the minus I and X
okay so the complex conjugate of fee n
is e to the minus I and X DX this is
actually really simple calculus okay if
I multiply these two functions I know
how to multiply exponential functions I
get e to the i-x times M minus n I'm
integrating this with respect to X and
so this is basically a constant times X
in the exponential my constant times X
so the integral of that is 1 over the
constant 1 over I M minus n e to the I M
minus n X evaluated from PI to minus PI
ok
okay so what is this equal if M is not
equal to n if n is different than n what
is this equal
right so this equals 0 if M is not equal
to n I'm trying to think of the best way
to explain why this is not equal to 0
because it's not obvious to me does
anyone know why this is not equal to I
this is equal to 0 because cosine have
positive things because of negative pi
so they cancel enough times the sine of
pi anything will be 0 so the sine parts
this is your perfect okay so this is 0
if M is not equal to n you can expand
this out in sines and cosines and verify
what about if m is equal to n
so if n is equal to n ok so this will be
equal to 1 this interval will be equal
to 1 so this interval will have to be 2
pi ok ok excellent thank you so what we
have is that these functions for
different m and n are completely
orthogonal in this L - inner product and
when M is equal to n they're in the same
direction obviously fie n is in the same
direction with itself and it has an
inner product with itself up to pi which
means that it's length is square root of
2 pi right the norm of any of these
vectors is root 2 pi ok so this is great
what we have is an orthogonal basis an
orthogonal function basis these are
basis directions these are vector
directions that are orthogonal to each
other
we have infinitely many of them and we
can essentially write any function we
have in this interval 0 to 2pi or 0 to L
we can write them in terms of these
basis functions
ok so let's let's go a little bit deeper
so how do we change coordinates in into
space let's just draw a picture as an
analogy so I really like analogies in to
space and three space because we
understand them ok so let's say I have
my X unit vector I have my Y unit vector
and let's say that I'm gonna have a
different coordinate system U and V ok
and I have some test vector I'm gonna
call it F because F could be a vector or
a function or whatever I have some
vector
okay how do I write this so the great
thing about vectors is that they're
purely geometric they don't care what
coordinate system I'm in if I have the
vector between me and my coffee cup the
most important vector in this room
doesn't matter what my coordinate system
is it doesn't matter if I'm in XY and Z
or XY and Z or if I turn over on my side
it doesn't matter what the coordinate
system is there's still a real geometric
vector connecting me to my coffee cup
but I can always take that vector and I
can write it in a coordinate system so
how would I do that
how would I write F in the coordinate
system of x and y okay so I could take
coast of the angle sine of the angle but
I don't know what the angle is what's
the more intrinsic definition of how I
could get in the x and y directions so I
want to break it down so that I have I
want how much of F is in the x-direction
and how much of f is in the y-direction
how do I find those numbers without
parts right so I have F is equal to the
inner product of F with the X factor in
the x-direction plus the inner product
of F with my Y vector in the Y Direction
this is how much of my X is in this
direction how much of F is in this
direction is just this is inner product
of F with X and how much of F is in this
direction is inner product of F with Y
yeah so I have this coordinate
representation of my vector F what if I
want to represent my vector in UV
coordinates how do I do that so just
first of all what does F look like in UV
coordinates so in UV coordinates I have
a minus V right like I'm in the negative
V Direction and I have a pretty large
positive U direction because I'm
aligned with you I have a pretty large
inner product with you okay so what is F
in my UV coordinates F dot you have
inner product u in the U Direction plus
F dot V in the V Direction okay I use
these brackets because sometimes it's
confusing to put a dots like sometimes
if I just put a dot between two
functions you might think I'm
multiplying them so I want to be
explicit that I'm doing this fancy
special inner product okay does this
make sense in 2d I can write my vector F
in any orthogonal coordinate system I
like in 2d as long as I take the inner
product of F with respect to those
coordinates and I write those
coefficients in those coordinate
directions that's how we change
coordinates okay so we can do the exact
same thing a fourier series is just a
coordinate transformation into the space
into the coordinates of these fee and
basis functions okay so let's let's
write this down
and I would strongly encourage you to
actually start coding these up like we
did on the Laplace equation for the
rectangle and start trying to take your
favorite functions and actually compute
these coefficients and compute these
Fourier transforms by hand we can
compute all of the integrals we can
compute these inner products see how
good these functions approximates using
sons of you know e to the I n X's okay
so as Fourier series is just another
change of coordinates okay a Fourier
series is a change of coordinates or a
change of basis that's another way of
saying it a change of coordinates or
change a basis of a function so now we
have a function f of X instead of our
vector F we have this i'm calling this
an infinite dimensional vector a
function f of x has infinite degrees of
freedom it could have any value you want
at any location in X so Fourier series
is a change of coordinates of our
function f into an infinite dimensional
orthogonal function space into an
infinite dimensional orthogonal function
space spanned by these sines and cosines
span by en equals e to the I M X ok so
let's do this how would I take my
function f and write it in these
coordinate systems in this coordinate
system with these orthogonal basis
vectors so let's write what I want so f
of X is going to equal
okay so I'm going to take the inner
product of F with respect to each of my
basis vectors so I want to write this
explicitly this is a function of X and
fee of X and our inner product is
integrating these things and this inner
product tells me how much of F is in
this direction how much of F is this
cosine and sine frequency so times PN of
X and just like in this example in 2d
and 3d I add up the contributions to
each of those directions so I have a sum
on this so I have a sum over n from
negative infinity to infinity because I
have you know these ends P go from
negative infinity to infinity
that's it this is my Fourier series this
is exactly what we derived before if you
write this down you'll see that this is
exactly what we've been writing down in
the last like three lectures this is
just an integral of F in cosine and sine
directions times cosines and sines of
those frequencies okay this is a good
time to stop for questions
all right this tax will sleep so this is
a good time for you to ask questions
anyone
yeah that's a good question here this is
general for complex valued functions
I could have f of X equals some complex
number if f of X is a real valued
function then we know that these
coefficients will be the calm
we know that for real valued f of X our
coefficient C of minus n negative n
coefficients are equal to the complex
conjugates of our positive end
coefficients so C minus v the minus v
coefficient is the complex conjugate of
the v coefficient we derived this in the
last class and so that would allow you
to take this infinite sum and write it
as a sum from N equals 1 to infinity of
you know two terms and a lot of stuff
will cancel out it actually simplify and
you have an N equals 0 term which is
just a flat like the the DC component or
the no frequency component of the of the
function ok other questions ok good
so the analogy between a 2d change of
coordinates and an infinite dimensional
change of coordinates like the math is
actually identical nothing changed but
let's start thinking about what this
actually means so yeah so if we wrote
let's just do this for real value
functions because I think this is
important and this might not be
absolutely correct I might be off by a
constants that I'll give you the general
idea and this is not in the notes so if
f of X is real valued then then this
becomes even a little bit simpler so we
have f of X equals some some constant
plus the inner product of f of X with
coasts and X in the coast n X Direction
plus some inner product of f of X with
sine and X in the sine and X direction
and if we wanted to be really fancy we
would say this equals a n this equals BN
we have a N equals integral minus PI to
PI of f of X coasts and X DX and BN
equals integral minus PI to PI of f of X
sine and X DX and I'm pretty sure this
is a naught over 2 where a naught is
just this integral with 1 here ok so
this is exactly what we've seen before
we wrote this exact same expression down
a bunch of time so we wrote this down
when we solved the Laplace equation on a
rectangle we also wrote this down in the
first lecture on Fourier series so this
is the Fourier series for real valued
functions that we're used to and this
pops out of this expression when you
make the restriction that f is real
valued and you have these this
relationship of these complex
coefficients that's exactly what you get
out ok
so in practice what do we do if we have
a new function so step zero I have a new
function how do i compute its Fourier
series sorry
I changed its coordinates how do I
actually do this like in a computer or
by hand what do I actually do if I have
a new function f of X and I want to
compute its Fourier series what do I do
yeah I would do some kind of a for-loop
either in my computer or by hand you
know I would do the for loop and I
basically write down these integrals and
I try to solve them okay so step one is
solve the inner product of F with cosine
and the inner product of F with sine
which means solving integrals ie solve
integrals now a lot of these integrals I
can solve by hand right like I know how
to integrate kosub and x times lots of
stuff right I've been you know we've
been good at integrating trigonometric
functions for a long time let's say that
I can't solve it analytically then I was
just doing a computer right I can
literally add up f of x times cos of x
times DX for a small DX from minus PI to
PI super-easy I can I can by you know
with a computer I can approximate these
so we either do this by hand or we
approximate with a computer and once we
have these a ends that's everything we
have the whole function we can write we
can approximate this function in terms
of sines and cosines so step two would
be you know reconstruct F according to
this function
okay so maybe a better question is why
would we want to do this this seems like
a huge hassle I have a function f of X
let's say it's x squared why would I
ever want to write it in sines and
cosines
Yeah right so I want to take this
function and I don't want to break it
down into its frequency components in
space like how much low-frequency how
much high-frequency what's happening in
this function why might I want to break
it down into frequency components how
many of you know what I mean when I say
break it down of the frequency
components how many would like a picture
so remember when we did this in the
computer we did a Fourier transform a
Fourier series for a step function and
that Fourier series for a step function
we kept adding up higher and higher
frequency sine waves remember we had
this function and our Fourier series
kind of did this and the more and more
frequencies we added the better the
agreement got okay so what we would like
to think is that maybe I can write this
function as some average value plus some
I don't really know how to draw this
very well plus some single frequency
sine wave plus sine of 2pi plus sine of
3pi
okay and so on and so forth saina 4 PI 5
PI 6 5 7 time forever and if I get the
right coefficients of these sine waves
and I add them all up I might actually
be able to reconstruct the shape it's
not even that crazy right I can almost
start to see it like I definitely need
this average because this thing has an
average and I might want to add this you
know single sine hump because this thing
has a big bump in the middle but then I
need this kind of sine of 3x a negative
one of those to cancel out the part of
the hump that's out here and I might
need a sign to the fifth and a sign to
the seven so I might have an odd sine
sequence to approximate this function
let me show you something like just in
Wikipedia has a really good
visualization of this actually
okay so this is a pretty good
visualization this is my step wave my
square wave approximated with one sign
with two signs three signs for signs and
so on it just gets better and better the
more of these signs you add and there's
this great visualization here okay let's
see if I can make this bigger I don't
know how to restart this movie
okay so you can see kind of these shaded
blue sine waves of different amplitudes
approximate this square wave and if you
add them all up there each individual
sine waves of their own frequency but if
you add them up in the right proportion
and the right Fourier coefficients these
are my inner product of F with my signs
if you add those single frequencies up
with the right proportions you can
approximate almost any function okay
any other questions about this this is a
pretty important concept and it is also
a little bit abstract and possibly
confusing any questions about this this
idea of changing coordinates into these
sines and cosines
yeah just one of their coefficients so
these are the coefficients that tell me
how much of cosine of you know a higher
frequency cosine wave is cosine of 100 X
versus cosine of 1 X the coast of 1 X is
a slow cosine coast of 100 X's you know
really rippling a lot and this inner
product tells me how much of that really
high-frequency cosine I need versus how
much of the low-frequency co-signing I
need to approximate this motion and in
general I'm going to need cosines and
sines to get any arbitrary function
unless they're odd or even okay so one
of the reasons I might want to take a
function and break it down into these
sine and cosine components is because in
my linear partial differential equation
so I have a linear PDE like u TT equals
k ux X this is the partial differential
equation for a guitar string ok so let's
say I take my guitar string and I pluck
this guitar string this is a linear
partial differential equation and maybe
if I pluck it I actually pull it down so
it looks kind of like that it's a
triangular wave initial condition it's
not anything nice it has all kinds of
frequency components but when I let this
thing go what I can do is I can say well
what does this PDE look like for this
single frequency sine wave and what does
it look like for this single frequency
sine wave and this one and this one and
all of them and it turns out that these
sine waves when you plugged it into this
PDE are really simple right if I take u
X X of a sine wave I get minus a sine
wave okay and so I I can essentially get
an ordinary differential equation for
the coefficients of each of these sine
waves and because this system is linear
I can solve each of those pure-tone PDE
problems individually and then I can add
them all up at the end so Fourier
transforms are going to allow me to
solve difficult PDE s in the frequency
domain so I'm going to solve how does
this partial differential equation
and change my frequencies and then I'm
gonna be able to reconfigure out what my
actual shape is on this guitar string
okay so that's why we're doing Fourier
transforms in the first place is because
they simplify our partial differential
equations a lot lots of PDEs are much
simpler in the frequency domain in the
Fourier transform coordinates that's why
we change coordinates ever like the only
reason we would ever change coordinates
is if it makes our lives simpler okay we
change to polar coordinates when we have
some kind of axis symmetry we change the
spherical coordinates when we're
symmetric in a sphere we change to
fourier co coefficients when it makes
our partial differential equations
simpler so what we're gonna find is that
if I write my function U as a sum of
sines and cosines
I can take my PDE and I can get n super
simple OD ease out and I know how to
solve
Odie's okay that's why we're doing this
in the first place
okay any questions before I go further
how many of you feel somewhat
comfortable with this how many of you do
not feel that comfortable with this yet
it's ok you don't have to it's going to
become a lot clearer why we care about
these things when we start solving PDEs
it's also going to become a lot clearer
why writing a function in terms of these
sine waves is nice and all of this
Fourier transform coordinate change
stuff becomes super simple when you do
it in the computer when you do this on
the discrete domain on vectors in a
computer it's to me it makes way more
sense ok but I want you to know the full
theory because it's very very very
important ok so we have a Fourier series
and it allows us to approximate lots of
functions that we care about so if I
have a function like that square wave
I'm able to approximate this function
really well let's say this is between 0
and L but what is my basic assumption in
Fourier series about these functions
from 0 to L they're periodic and so what
I'm actually simulating what I'm
actually representing because these sine
waves don't just stop at L they keep
going and they have you know more stuff
forever positive X to infinity negative
X to infinity so really I also have all
of this other crap that is being
represented by my Fourier series and I
might not want all of that other stuff I
might actually have a function which is
just a square wave and then nothing else
to infinity and my Fourier series does
not capture that my Fourier series by
definition is going to force repetition
for every 2 L 3 L 4 L okay so my Fourier
series does not allow me to represent
all functions on the entire domain it
only allows me to represent periodic
functions purely periodic so the most
important generalization of the Fourier
series is something
called the Fourier integral transform so
I'm sure most of you have seen the
Fourier transform at some point written
as a big integral and that's what we're
gonna write right now and the Fourier
transform this integral is actually
what's the most useful for partial
differential equations okay so how do I
want to do this okay so we're gonna take
our Fourier series on minus L to L and
take the limit as L goes to infinity so
we're gonna define this for functions
minus L to L and then we're gonna take
the limit as those goes to infinity and
we'll be able to represent any function
right so we had our f of X equals a
naught over - I shouldn't have erased
this sum N equals 1 to infinity of a and
Coast's and PI x over L plus B and sine
and PI x over L these coefficients a and
n are just the inner product of my
function with these basis functions just
integral inner product I could write
this as 1 over 2 L sum from minus
infinity to infinity of f of X inner
product with the N of X in the fee and
of X Direction totally fine that's the
change of coordinates and so f is
represented as an infinite sum of sines
and cosines
with frequencies these are kind of
discretized or quantized frequencies
given by Omega N equals n PI over L okay
okay this is just summarizing everything
we've done over the last two or
two-and-a-half lectures so we're gonna
write down this Fourier series from
minus L over 2 to L over 2 or from 0 to
L I guess from minus L to L and we're
gonna take L as it goes to infinity I
really need a better black pen okay so
if we take L goes to infinity I'm going
to define Omega equals n PI over L and
Delta Omega is just PI over L so these
are kind of my Delta frequency elements
I keep increasing my frequency by these
increments and we're gonna take the
limit as L goes to infinity which is the
same as the limit as Delta W goes to 0
I'm gonna make my frequency spacing
infinitesimally close okay so if I have
f of X equals the limit as Delta W goes
to 0 of that infinite sum there side
this sum of minus infinity to infinity
my inner product term my coefficients
I'm just gonna write this out explicitly
it's WL over 2 pi integral from minus PI
over Delta W to pi over Delta W F
I'm gonna tell you what I'm doing here
in a minute
this is a long shitty expression okay
this is just L and minus L this is inner
product of F with BM right this is PN
this is F I'm integrating from minus L
to L and I just have some dummy variable
that I'm integrating with respect to you
so that we don't get confused so I the
inner product of F with this basis
function times this basis function okay
that's what we have and this whole
formula here we're going to define as if
we take the limit as Delta W goes to 0
this is the integral from minus infinity
to infinity of f of C each of the minus
I and I Omega C and this is the
definition of our Fourier transform
that's it that's the Fourier transform
this is the definition of my Fourier
transform
okay so let's think about how to
interpret this we can write our function
as an infinite sum of basis functions
and these are the coefficients of those
basis functions so my Fourier transform
is essentially just the coefficients of
these frequency components and I take
the limit as Delta W goes to 0 so that
my domain instead of from negative L to
L it goes from negative infinity to
infinity
I'm taking the limit as my domain gets
infinitely large and these coefficients
these are just my CN these are just the
CN from before but I've taken the limit
as my domain goes to infinity and we
call this f hat and it's a function of
Omega I'm integrating this C out and I
just get a function of Omega and Omega
is my frequency if the frequency of the
sines and cosines so my Fourier
transform are how much of f are in each
of those sine and cosine directions how
much of that you know for a given Omega
how much of F has that sine and cosine
of Omega in it
okay so why did we go in Fourier series
to Fourier transform integral you want
to generalize this for non periodic
functions I want to be able to have a
function that does nothing and then does
some stuff and then does nothing again
and I don't want to make it I don't want
to constraint it to be periodic so I
want to take the limit as L goes to
infinity and when I do that instead of
just discrete coefficients C 1 C 2 C 3 C
4 for the you know each of these modes I
have a whole function of Omega so before
I had you know C 1 is the coefficient of
you know my basic first period sine wave
and C 2 is the coefficient of you know
my second sine wave and so on and so
forth I had just like countably infinite
ly many I had 1 2 3 all the way up to
infinitely many of these coefficients
but when I took the limit as L goes to
infinity the spacing between my
frequencies went to 0 and instead of
discrete frequencies I have a continuum
of frequencies I can have every
frequency between here and here I have
an entire function of all frequencies I
can plug in 2 pi or 2 pi plus 0.0001 I
can plug in any frequency I like here
and I can tell how much of my function
is in that exact sine or cosine
frequency it's a little weird ok this is
going to take some time to digest I
don't expect this to be like super
obvious at the beginning but what I'm
getting at is that this Fourier
transform that almost all of you have
seen before just may be defined this is
the generalization of a Fourier series
this is just a way of saying we're
integrating we're adding up a bunch of
sines and cosines in this amount
we're adding our function is just the
sum of a bunch of sines and cosines in
this amount each of those sines and
cosines has this coefficient out front
okay we're gonna learn more about this
we're gonna look at properties and
generalizations and how we can use this
for partial differential equations on
Monday okay the final is due today at
5:00 under my door or in hand have a
great weekend thank you